From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
All right. I'm Emilye Crosby working with the Southern Oral History Program University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
And I'm here today conducting this oral history as part of the Civil Rights History Project,
which is an undertaking of Smithsonian Institution's National Museum of African American History and Culture
and the American Folklife Center in the Library of Congress.
This is June 25th, 2013, and we're here today with Mr. William Lucy at the Smithsonian offices
and the other people present at the interview are John Bishop, who's filming Elaine Nichols of the Smithsonian African American Museum and Charmin Townsend.
Mr. Lucy, would you be willing to tell me a little bit about your family and growing up?
I understand you were born in Memphis and moved to California.
Born in the city of Memphis, my father was from a Catherine, Alabama, my mother was from a Uniontown, Alabama.
I grew up in Memphis up until about the age of seven plus.
I moved to California in March of 1942 just after World War II started.
I actually grew up in Richmond, California from about seven plus years old until I left Richmond in 1966.
Was the 1966, is when you left Richmond?
Yes.
Was the war the reason that your family went from Memphis to California?
Yes. My father worked for Memphis Light, Gas and Water until the war started in December of 1941.
He, along with any number of folks, were recruited for the war effort.
They left from Memphis and went to the Bay Area and went to work for Kaiser shipyards.
Did they have any trouble leaving Memphis, do you know?
Not at all. At that time, the government was recruiting for the war effort.
Yeah. So, do you have any memories of Memphis from those early days?
Well, I went to elementary school and Memphis to about the fifth grade, I think it was fourth of fifth grade.
And Memphis was pretty typical of most cities in the south, segregated as it could get.
The political participation was under the thumb of a fellow by the name of Edward Hull "E.H." Crump.
My father received his job from Mr. Crump and worked for Memphis Light, Gas and Water until we left in 1941.
But mid-December, we left in about March in 1942.
So, after you moved to California, what was it like for you there?
Well, in the early years, it was a total war effort. Up until the war ended in about 1945.
I went to Memphis Elementary School and California and then went to junior high and high school in California.
And California was radically different than Memphis Tennessee.
Of course, I was young and didn't know the significance of the difference.
We all lived in a wartime house and projects.
Everybody lived together. Kaiser Shipyards had developed four shipyards in Memphis, I mean in Richmond proper.
And virtually everybody in Richmond worked for either standard oil, Ford Motor Company, or work for Kaiser in the shipyards.
When you say we all lived together, that's the workers?
Workers, I mean there was tremendous amount of defense housing built for the war effort.
And is this integrated housing? It was in.
Okay. So, do you have good memories of those years?
A very good memories. Our schooling was good, segregated but good.
Through junior high school, it was a good environment. When the war ended, the assumption was that people would go back where they came from and turned out not to be quite true.
You had a number of people who went to different states but the bulk of the African American community remained in Richmond until it came a point in time to really remove the defense housing.
But our early childhood was pretty good. The education system was radically different than Memphis Tennessee, both through junior high school and high school.
Were you aware of that at the time? I mean was it very noticeable to you as a child?
The only thing that was noticeable is that we didn't have a substantial number of white people there.
We had the Mexican Americans and African Americans all living in the same area.
Okay. So, after the war, did your father continue to work with Kaiser?
No. At the close of the war effort, he opened his own business. He was a mechanic.
I guess, self-taught. He worked on automobiles, trucks, heavy equipment, construction equipment. He did that for a number of years.
Can you describe your parents for us? Tell us about them a little?
I think there were typical people from the south, primarily from the rural south.
My father, I'm not quite sure of the level of education that he achieved but he was fundamentally self-taught.
He worked, as I said, for Memphis Light, Gas and Water. And what was interesting, he was, I saw his work papers and he was described as an unskilled laborer.
Prior to the war effort, six weeks after he went to work for Kaiser, he was a journeyman welder.
And that's not true from that is when the government has a priority, it can be achieved, whatever they have to do to make it happen.
My mother was a seamstress for many years and then opened a restaurant.
I'm not quite sure of the years but she ran that for a number of some time.
Did you have brothers and sisters? One brother in my, Joe Lucy Jr. who was two years older than myself.
And so after you, are there other significant memories that you have from your childhood, things that were important or formative for you?
Well, I mean we had a typical growing up experience as youngsters in junior high school and high school.
We did the sports thing, baseball, basketball, football. After graduation from high school, I attended El Cerrito High School as opposed to Richmond High School.
And our sort of growing up years was just like the thousands of other kids in the center of situation.
We all went to school together, we all played together, we all grew up together and many of us still maintain contact now.
And after you graduated from high school, you went to Berkeley?
I went to work first for the Mare Island Naval Shipyard and worked there for two years.
In 1953, I went to work for Contra Costa County, California in the engineering department.
And during the course of that work went to the University of California at Berkeley in the amateur of the research courses.
And I shouldn't say worked in that but studied that for a couple years at the same time working for the county.
Was that something where they would pay you to go to school or was something that you were interested in?
No, this was done to enhance my opportunity for promotion on my regular work schedule.
I worked at Contra Costa County, California in the materials and research laboratory.
And at that time this was a very new area of study for highway construction, roads, buildings, dams, bridges.
So what was your work at that time?
I was initially what's called an engineering aid which was the entry level position in the laboratory system.
I worked at that for about three years then transferred to the same department to the survey and right away division.
I came back into the laboratory and ultimately worked 13 years for the county, all but one or two of them in the materials and research department.
When I left employment in the county, I was the system materials and research engineer for the county.
And how was the work you did then different than your entry level work?
Well, there was a series of positions in the laboratory involved both laboratory testing and there's basically quality control and design and materials for highway construction.
The entry level was basically taking samples and doing sort of the fundamental test activity.
When I became a super what was called a supervised and material stester, I ran the laboratory with about seven or eight personnel under my supervision.
The series of civil engineers, the system civil engineers, junior civil engineers, all of them working on quality control tests for highway construction, water, asphalt, oils.
And in 1953, I believe when Federal-Aid Highway Act of 1956 under the system, states had to be responsible for the quality control of materials that would enter construction.
And counties assumed their responsibility of a farm to the freeway road development.
Could we take a little pause? Okay, we're back on.
How did you get involved in working with the union?
While I was working at the county, I was invited to join the union.
So I joined what at that time was an employee association.
During the course of the association work, the issue became why are we not a union?
I mean, we were in a very heavily unionized county, a very heavily unionized state.
And we were a civil service organization and there were many of us who believed that the civil service system did not meet our needs.
Civil service in those days had gone far beyond its original mandate of testing for qualified employees to be submitted for hire.
Civil service systems had began to make decisions on wages, benefits, etc.
Which I basically felt was an issue that should be decided upon by the employer and the employees in some sort of a formal bargaining process.
So we discussed and debated and put the issue to a sort of a year long forum on whether we should be a union or continue to be an association.
And the employees who were part of our membership voted to seek out the maze and means of becoming a legitimate union in the true sense.
We had that election, the pro union group won the election, we set out to become a true collective bargaining vehicle.
Sounds like you were pretty actively involved in that discussion?
Well, I'm sure there were others who were perhaps more active, but at least I put a good deal of time into the issue because I thought it was so basic.
Yeah. What were the things that struck you as most important at the time about being part of a union?
Well, the process in the civil service system, which is a good system, was a good system in our county.
But the issue of wages, hours, and conditions of employment as an association civil servant, you could protest after something had happened to you.
You didn't have a whole lot of rights in that process.
We thought that there should be legitimate grievance procedures with the defined process for resolution of just day-to-day problems.
And we certainly felt that, in regard to wages and benefits, employees have a basic right to be a part of that discussion that determines that.
Do you have looking back where there are influences in your growing opera, your experiences that predisposed you to that?
Well, I was employed in the county. I met a number of people who were old trade unionists.
I think probably the two that had the greatest impact and influence on myself was a fellow by the name of Ben Russell, who worked for the county government at that time in the civil service department.
Another fellow by the name of Red Ielo, who was a blacksmith, you could have a wider difference between the functions and both of them felt very strongly about the need to have a trade union, truly represented people in the true trade union system.
And I think Mr. Ielo probably had more to do with the formation of thought.
But the two of them had a tremendous influence on how I felt about our rights as employees to a process where we were recognized as participants in decisions that affected our work life.
And am I correct that you went from working for the county to working for the union?
Yes.
So can you describe sort of how you made that evolution to actually become a full time employee for the union?
Well, our union after going through this year long discussion and debate about trade unionism versus association functions.
And I learned a lot and I think grew a lot.
And in the course of the union's action, a contest between who did we want to join since we had made the decision to be a union, what union and who.
And during those days, there were not many unions who thought that should be redactively in the public sector.
If you recall, President Franklin D. Roosevelt, when he passed the National Labor Relations Act, specifically excluded public employees.
And we used to make the case of what's the difference between a bus driver and the private sector who drives his bus, ten blocks.
And then a public employee drives it another ten. They both do the same thing, requiring the same skills.
And they therefore have the same basic rights to wages and benefits.
And so we caught the attention of the American Federation of State, County and Municipal Employees.
At that time, who was led by a fellow out of Wisconsin, Mr. Arnold S. Zander,
who had grown up in the public service. He was the president, but he was being challenged by a fellow out of New York by the name of Jerry Wurf.
We had a very clear vision of what workers in the public are private sector ought to be entitled to.
And so they saw what we were doing and what we were talking about.
And in 1964, in the contest for the leadership of the union, Mr. Wurf was successful.
So we replaced a pro civil service leader with a pro union leader.
And Mr. Wurf, in about a year or so, saw the worker that we were trying to do in the kinds of issues we were focusing on.
And asked if I'd be interested in coming to work for the National.
And I was a little reluctant because I had only been out of my zip code one time.
So we talked about it in the question of what can we do if we have the sort of pro worker sense about ourselves.
And the public sector, the collective bargaining was very, very new.
And it was my belief that if our union was able to impact on issues, both work issues and social issues,
maybe a union as an institution could be a good vehicle for a social change.
So as a result of that thinking you went ahead and made the leap to spot your concerns?
Yes, I left the county service in about June of 1966 and came to work for the National.
As the Associate Director of the Department of Legislation and Community Affairs.
And so what you said that one of your hesitations is you'd only been out of your zip code one time.
Well, from Memphis to California.
And what was the new job going to entail? Was it going to be relocating or travel?
Oh, it meant relocating from Richmond, California to Washington, D.C.
The scope of the work was very unclear.
What we did see, however, was the growing influence of the federal sector in the affairs of state and local government.
I don't mean negatively, but funding programs, rules and regulations that related to how things were to be done.
In our union, we were growing union in the public sector.
We felt we had to have a presence in those discussions, whether it was social welfare or whether it was employment security,
that we had to have at least a voice in the process in order to be sure how it will affect our workers.
So during this same period, the Southern Civil Rights Movement is taking place.
So from probably when you're a what a young adult, into this transition to the National.
So what was your awareness of that?
Well, if you live in the South, you're aware of civil rights, either presence or absence all the time.
Much of our thought, synonym to areas, there was a great struggle among agricultural workers at that time, particularly farm workers.
Cesar Chavez, another fellow by the name of Larry Itliong was in the process of forming the United Farm Workers.
And they were engaged in a big struggle in Central California with the Gallo around the grape industry.
Later on, it went on to lettuce and other things.
Our union and many of our folks identified with that.
So we were quite aware of the power and the pressure that major agribusiness could put on workers.
Same in the civil rights struggle, the real issue of Southern Civil Rights fighting was really about economic exploitation.
The same as it was with the Mexican farm workers.
And so did you think about it through that time period?
We thought about it, but that was at that point a whole lot we could do.
I believe, like Dr. Martin Luther King Jr believed, that trade unions as an institution can have great impact on the processes that govern people's lives.
But I didn't understand how those could be implemented.
What probably had a major piece of it, major people influence, was when we took on the simple question of survivor benefits for descendants of Panama Canal construction workers.
The descendants were without any benefits whatsoever, even though our ships were sailing easily through the canal.
Just think about three hands full of these people left.
The government has a basic responsibility, I think, to do something for them.
So under the affairs of our department, we began to look at this issue.
Secondly, the whole question of minimum wages and the areas that were left out of consideration for minimum wage status.
These areas were by large African-American workers, in contrast to the others who were workers from all down the southern hemisphere.
These were workers who would deny minimum wage covers, people who worked in private hospitals, nursing homes.
As we thought about this, this really required some involvement of the union if we were going to raise the issue.
And we did, and we ultimately were victorious in getting coverage under the interstate commerce clause for these workers.
Was there a minimum wage change in 1966 that extended agricultural workers?
I don't recall that, but I think it was about 66-67 under the interstate commerce clause that they extended it to private hospitals and nursing homes.
What I'm thinking of, and I'm not exactly sure of the date, but there was a period, I think, right after the Voting Rights Act passed, sort of in that time frame, where there was, I think, a dollar and an hour minimum wage for agricultural workers, which became the impetus for plantation owners and the delta to sort of finish mechanization and just completely run people.
Off the plantations, which is part of what led to the poverty, the extreme hunger that led Marian Wright Edelman to propose the poor people's campaign with King.
And so I was wondering if you were aware of the year.
I'm just not aware of that, but it's clear that the minimum wage is both a blessing and a curse, I mean, because the employers simply take advantage of workers in certain categories.
And there's a real need to see the minimum wage really as almost a floor for the improvement of the life of folks who either subscaled or unscaled, but doing medial work for which the employer decides the value.
In your extensive work, do you have ideas for better ways to protect workers' rights and access to living wages and minimum wage?
I think collective bargaining is a simple, pure system, I mean, where workers have only their work to put into the game.
The employers have to measure the value of that and you can't do it unless the two of them come together on the worker side, they have the right to withdraw their labor.
On the employer side, they have the decision to make about profit versus various fairness and generally they choose profit.
And so absent a vehicle for workers to participate fully in the decision that affects them, you can always have exploitation.
When you came to Washington working for the Union full time, were there people who were important influences when you moved into that new job?
Yeah, the fellow who the president works in out to talk to me about his fellow by the Al Bilik.
And our unions are very, very, I mean, our union was not new, but our philosophy had changed substantially and we were making the case that public employees had the same rights as private sector employees.
I mean, there's fundamentally no difference in what many of us did and the fact that the civil service systems that said early had gone far beyond this mandate, we felt that we were entitled fully to if we if workers so chose to organize, to organize, be recognized and bargain the contract like it workers in the private sector.
And that was so very new and the proof of his newness was that public sector workers were to join us by the thousands because they never had or heard this kind of presentation to them as their rights.
And there were no, there were one or two states that allowed the process but not necessarily have the laws that protected workers in that process.
There were many elected officials who saw the unfairness of the system who were prepared who actually bargain with public sector entities and proceeded to politically achieve the results of the process.
Of bargaining, I mean, the old argument was that the city, the county, the state is sort of a supreme power and the taxpayers, you know, pay the way well of the fact there's that they are sovereign entities but they're basically responsibilities provide public service.
And so they're employers at the same time.
So you end up being involved in the Memphis strike?
Well, like a lot of people I got caught in the wrong place at the wrong time.
I was, as I say, doing legislation and community affairs which is something that I was an alerting phase, this is 1968.
I was, I ran into the president in the hallway one day and he says, what are you doing for the next couple of days?
I said, what I've been doing for the last couple of days.
So I'd like you to go to Detroit and do some work there.
And I agreed to do it and it called me back a little while later and says there's something going on in Memphis.
You're from Memphis, perhaps you could go down, take a look and see what it means.
The sanitation department in Memphis Tennessee was sort of in turmoil.
You had men who had worked there to better part of their adult life and still earn in wages that allowed them to qualify for every poverty program that existed.
As Dr. Martin Luther King Jr once said, it was really the true story of the working poor.
Well, they were caught in a political squeeze between a brand new mayor who had got elected in a brand new system of governance.
And he won his election on probably some of the strongest racial things that had been seen for a long time.
So he felt he owed to black community and nothing.
And he certainly in his new found power was not going to tolerate a union, talk about safety and health and wages and those kinds of things.
So a steelmate developed between a brand new mayor and a brand new system of city government.
Prior to the strike start and there had been an attempt by these workers to influence the city.
They were enjoying by the local court from that.
The catalyst to this new effort was men getting killed in the back of their garbage truck by the packing mechanism that scooped up the garbage and forced it into the back of the truck.
This system had in the equipment had been complained about for some time.
But the city, a new government, new mayor, old problems.
They didn't see the need to address any of those problems at this time.
This sort of festored for a while and then the catalyst, as I said, was the men being crushed in the back of the truck.
The remaining workforce is that we just had enough of this.
Well, the last thing you need in a city like Memphis, Tennessee in February is a garbage strike.
I mean, strikes don't come because workers are mad. Strikes become because they're frustrated and have no ability to resolve the issues that contribute to the frustration.
So they were preparing the strike to do something.
I went from Detroit to Memphis just to get sort of a look at what was going on.
It was clear that this was a major issue that wasn't going to resolve itself in 24 hours because the city was entrenched in this position and the workers were in there.
And I sort of passed this on to the president and we thought about it for a minute.
We were subsequently notified by the Washington Posts.
He fell off from the Washington Post. I can't recall his name now, but he was coming back oddly enough from a meeting in Marks, Mississippi that Dr. Martin Luther King Jr had been in as a part of his early movement towards the poor people's campaign.
And so they called us and said, it looks like there's a strike in Memphis, Tennessee.
I mean, there's a strike in Memphis, Tennessee. He said, you ought to check it out.
So we did again and this through the men had refused to, in the process of refusing to go to work.
And ultimately, they took that position.
And I was there to work with them myself.
I fell about a name of Jesse Epps.
Another fell about a name of Joe Paisley.
And what we tried to do was just give some direction and some support to the workers until we figure out exactly what we're up against.
And the strike just got bigger and bigger.
It was a classic confrontation between a city with total power and a group of workers with no power other than a good idea.
And the strike lasted for 67 days.
And clearly the story was Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
Ultimately, saw this as a great contradiction.
The rich nations and certainly rich cities yet to have people working for wages which will not allow them to bring themselves out of poverty.
And if you work every day, you ought to earn a wage sufficient to allow you to raise your family and so forth.
During the course of the strike in the early days, Roy Wilkins by a restaurant.
And ultimately, Dr. Martin Luther King Jr, this was a very quiet strike.
I mean, it was not well known outside of the city of Memphis.
And we tried to ask people to come down and take a look, identify with it, who would bring some press with them because the Southern press don't give you a whole lot of play on worker activity.
And then when Dr. Martin Luther King Jr came because he was traveling with the National Press, people had to have to see exactly what was taking place.
And my hat and heart goes out to the men who participated in that because, I mean, whatever they had, it was on the line in that struggle.
How did having Dr. Martin Luther King Jr come in change the dynamics of the strike and what you were trying to do or able to do?
Well, we had spent a good deal of time trying to keep this as an imploreal, imploreal issue.
And because we felt pretty strongly that if it became a question of a racial polarization that would be little sympathy for the men themselves because nobody knew anything about sanitation work.
But it was impossible to do that. I mean, all of the elements suggested that you were going to ultimately wind up there.
What Dr. Martin Luther King Jr did was make this analogy that here is the problem in America.
You've got people who work every day but don't earn a sufficient enough wage to get themselves out of poverty.
We did an analysis of all the workers in that participation in 85-90% of them qualified for public aid, yet they worked every day.
And as we sort of talked to people, we really began to understand that people had no sense of the role that sanitation workers play in the social service system.
And I think many of them thought they just put the garbage out and it disappeared overnight as opposed to somebody getting up at 4 o'clock in the morning and coming by, picking it up, putting it on that shoulder, taking it around, throwing it in the truck.
So is this people in Memphis that you're talking to?
I think that's where everyone's people generally cross countrymen.
I mean, the last person you generally think about is somebody who picks up your garbage.
I was on a radio show once out of New York and Westchester County, New York, which at that time was probably still pretty well to do.
So a lady called in and just told them about making comments about you're paid for the value of what you do.
I said, well, that's not quite true.
She said, well, you know what I mean? I don't know what you're saying.
I mean, if you waited until about June or July, a garbage sanitation worker is somewhat more important than a lawyer in the context of the impact they have on public health.
And so it was very quiet for a little while on the phone.
And she said, well, thank you for your answer.
Well, I thank you for your question because there's a lack of assessed value of public services.
And the well to do, tend not to need public services.
And so you have these contradictions.
If you get into a debate about a tax increase for sanitation work, you're probably not going to make it.
So as opposed to if you want to build a sports arena.
There was quite a bit of organizing throughout the Memphis community relation to the strike.
We had to first get people to understand what was taking place.
Because these men, as I said before, had never been seriously thought on.
What we asked them to do, because they touch every home in the city once or twice a week.
And we asked them if they would do two things.
If they have decided to make this confrontation, first of all, they need to go back home and talk to their wives.
Because the last thing you need is home pressure if you're in the middle of a confrontation.
And the second thing is to take a separate leak that leave it at the home of every home you touch in the course of your day's work.
And explain to people what it is that's taking place.
So at least the neutral at best and hopefully some would be supportive.
And that's what we got.
We got pretty much solid support in the African American community.
Because these are the people who live next door.
We got a lukewarm support in the white community because they just had an election for a new form of government and new political leadership.
And the belief was that the National had come down to take advantage of the city of Memphis.
Some of this fostered by the FBI under J. Edgar Hoover.
But for a union that's somewhat mature, the last thing you're going to have in the winter is a garbage strike in Memphis, Tennessee.
And we were able, slowly but surely, to attract the religious community, at least to listen to the discussion and debate.
Ultimately, we wanted them to support us too.
But I mean, it took a while because the South, not just in the white community, but the Black community also, was not tuned into public sector trade unionism.
I know that the slogan that you see on the sides, I am a man.
And I know a historian who's written some interesting things about sort of what that means in terms of men and women.
And that some people have really focused on this as something about manhood.
And she says, you can look at pictures and see the huge numbers of women out on the streets protesting this.
And she argues that it's a lot more complex than that.
Oh, it is.
In spite of the wages, benefits, and lack of safety and all that kind of stuff, there were no tangible demands on the table that was the core of the strike.
It was the lack of respect, the absence of dignity, that caused these workers to say, we just had enough.
It was just really so hard to define.
I mean, if you talk to a reporter, he says, well, what's this about?
You say respect and dignity. It's all right.
There was just no understanding of it.
And the men themselves, you know, you could listen to them talk.
And you could see that for many of them, this is our first stand against a system that had virtually robbed them of any self-respect.
Both as workers and even in their homes.
You know, children who really didn't believe they were doing anything worthwhile.
And so Rev. James M. Lawson Jr, who joined the strike early in the early days, had a press conference one day.
And he was defining racism.
And he says that racism in the context of what we were talking about was when a person treats a man like he's not a man.
And we didn't think about that much at that point, but it became very clear that we had to have something that held this thing together.
So one of the local ministers in myself was charged with going out, figuring out something.
We said down on even that the Peabody Hotel there in Memphis, Tennessee.
And we just started sort of playing with words and what had you.
And what came to us was a statement that Rev. James M. Lawson Jr had made earlier.
And we tried to put this as simple as possible.
And if you've seen one of the signs, they sort of blocked letters, you know, forwards.
And it simply said, I am a man.
And the impact of that on the workers, I mean, it defined for them all that they were about.
Because these were like young workers. These were men who were middle age or older at that time.
And I think they were replaying some of the disrespect they had heard.
Because you don't understand, if you could go from boy to uncle to grandpa without ever stopping at men.
And so they were so proud that this sign defined what they saw as their struggle.
And can you talk about how you can have that slogan and my understanding is it doesn't exclude women.
That there's still, you know, the women identify with this issue and not in the same way,
but in a significant way that invites their participation.
Well, I mean, if it had not been for the women, we'd still be on strike in Memphis.
I mean, women-wise neighbors did so much to give their support to the effort.
This was in no way a sort of a macho kind of thing.
It was much more an emotional kind of thing and an expression of the frustrations that they had experienced over time.
Not being able to play the simple role that a man would play in a family setting.
It was just tremendous women support.
And everybody had a role to play.
Can you talk more about the different kinds of contributions, different people, different groups made?
Well, by the time we got into a button, midway the strike.
We had logistical needs like you wouldn't believe.
We had feeding needs.
We had all kind of economic needs.
The church's role became sort of spiritual every day.
We had to have an activity that gave people a chance to vent, you know.
So the women would cook.
The women would do the office work.
The women would march on the picket lines.
I mean, they did everything that they needed in order to make the strike successful.
And it's, I mean, there's a tremendous story that needs to be told about the role that women played in the Memphis Sanitation Strike.
And what about Reverend Lawson?
You mentioned him a minute ago.
Rev. James M. Lawson Jr was one of the unique individuals who had been a long time aid in ally of Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
Rev. James M. Lawson Jr had studied, had studied Mohandas K. Gandhi tactics or studied under Mohandas K. Gandhi.
I'm not sure which one maybe both.
But it was a very strong spiritual leader in the Memphis community.
And he identified with the strike very early.
And so the earn the reputation of becoming the most hated African American in Memphis.
Which was very, it was fine with Rev. James M. Lawson Jr.
But he brought to the strike a sort of a new kind of vision in a very both emotional and intellectual context.
And he helped to mobilize other ministers to come to the aid of the strike.
You know, the story that the black church was right there instantly is sort of, you know, a little bit of a license for whoever writes it.
Because the African American church had a little, if any experience with the Union's period.
And public sector, the Union's probably none whatsoever.
And so people did not want to be dragged into a fight that they didn't understand.
And so it took some time for them to become very clear on what the issues were.
And why the issues were having such impact on these men.
I mean, many people thought they would go back to work the next day.
But they didn't. They chose the strike.
And no union can force people to strike.
You know, work a strike out of frustration that their problems will not be dealt with.
I'm sure there's, I know that there's a lot more I could ask you on Memphis.
But I want to make sure we touch on a couple of other things as well.
Let me just make this last point about Memphis.
Dr. Martin Luther King Jr saw this, as I said, is the ultimate contradiction for people who work every day,
but still cannot lift themselves out of poverty.
So he aligned the Memphis strike with support people's campaign.
And he was just totally committed to it.
He came to Memphis twice.
The first speech he gave, as we say, a barn burner.
And his second preparation for the march, he was killed on April 4.
Dr. Martin Luther King Jr gave what has now come to him, you know, is I've Been to the Mountaintop" speech,
which was one of the better bringing together of the struggle of workers
and contrasting with the richness of the country, the March on Washington for Jobs and Freedom, the struggles,
because these men had fought for the country in the World War II.
He just saw this as the great contradiction.
And the tragedy is that the powers to be in Memphis did not listen to what he was suggesting,
because his assassination did not have to take place.
And I'm not one of those who have still convinced that James Earl Ray,
as a lone person did this.
I mean, you've got a burglar who gets from Memphis to Europe with no support.
That's kind of a stretch.
How did...
I know that one of the things that people talk about in terms of Kane coming to Memphis
and the two visits is the issue of nonviolence.
And so maybe we could speak to that.
Well, there were young folks at Memphis who thought that tactics were less sufficient.
And they were anxious to get engaged in the strike support effort.
There was a group there called the The Invaders, The Invaders,
a whole bunch of young kids who were community-minded and certainly committed to the benefit of the community,
but promoting violence, that wasn't them.
As a record shows, and certainly Senate Select Committee on Intelligence Activities a year or so later,
I showed that many of those who participated in the violence were provocateurs.
Some from the FBI service, and I guess some from other places,
but on the day of the last King March, the window breaking in all of the violence and damage,
this was a compilation of things.
And it was not young people by themselves. It was provocateurs.
And the sad part, it has never been a full review of that participation.
Yeah.
And I think the effort was to ruin King's image as not being able to, at that point in time,
hold a nonviolent assembly, whether it be a march or a rally.
I know that there was concern for King and others in SCLC about what the implications of this would be for the poor people's campaign,
bringing so many people to Washington.
Well, I think that was, I think, the thrust, and probably the alleged pain that made some folks decide to help the violence.
I mean, trade unions will discipline people.
I mean, the violence is not an asset.
And what they used it for on that day was to polarize the city, the county, and the state.
And they succeeded in doing just that because it's right.
We think would have been shortened, absent the violence.
The mayor brought in the National Guard and a whole new set of dynamics were put into play.
What were your interactions with Dr. Martin Luther King Jr in that context?
I made with him only once at the Rivermont Hotel at the end of the march that was broken up that day.
I forget the date.
And it was just an analysis of what took place.
I was in meetings where he was present with a lot of other folks with that day.
He said that he talked about the down side of what had happened.
What was that like, that meeting like?
It had been a pretty exciting day.
And we were trying to assess it.
We were trying to figure out what do we do next?
And of real concern, what are we exposing these men to?
What are we allowing them to expose themselves to?
And the word was, it has to be another march.
So what kind of impact did his assassination have on the, from your perspective, the Memphis strike?
And maybe you personally?
Well, let me do the last one for that incredible life-old and experienced only personally.
Because you know, it's just unbelievable that something like this could happen.
Totally unnecessary.
But in the context of the strike tactics,
we heard one reporter from a local paper wrote an article that said he was just so sorry that Dr. Martin Luther King Jr had been killed in Memphis,
with emphasis on in Memphis.
So for us who were staff, I mean, our commitment was pushed to the hill.
I mean, we had to do something with this thing.
But we at first had to resolve the question of street violence.
Not so much by strikers, by other people who were just so frustrated over the assassination of Dr. Martin Luther King Jr.
And then you had a whole lot of whackles from other places.
You know, Arkansas, Mississippi, et cetera.
Who saw this as an opportunity to act out some of their peanut up hostility.
So we in Memphis had to get a system of safety for strikers.
We had to sort of help the church and other parts of the community.
Provide a sense of protection for people who were going to be exposed as the police were.
We're just openly hostile.
So we had to work on that.
And at the same time, we have to decide what the men wanted to do.
And they were ready to go back as they say downtown because the marches were from Clayborn Temple AME Church to City Hall.
So after the memorial service, you know, which was held, I guess a week or so later, a couple of weeks later after this funeral service in Atlanta, we got back to strike tactics.
President Lyndon B. Johnson gave us a tremendous amount of, have I shouldn't say, gave us, but in an effort to resolve the issue assigned James J. Reynolds.
As a mediator in this process, and Mr. Reynolds searched out and found a fellow by the name of Frank Miles to work with.
Because even the mayor just refused and negotiate, refused to discuss, you'll post it for the cameras, et cetera.
And it was really time to resolve this.
In contrast, in the fact, we had resolved this strike twice before.
So I mean, Dr. Martin Luther King Jr's passing on, sure, put some pressure into that situation.
I know you said initially you were trying very hard to keep it as a labor issue.
But clearly with King's involvement, it becomes very identified with civil rights.
Well, it became that before King came.
There were civil rights activists in town.
They were not, they said, who knew the thing about the union, but they just saw men on strike.
In fact, at 99.9% of more African Americans, you know, sort of say what it said.
So how did that, I mean, did you, in the end, did you think that was a good thing, or did it change your thinking on that at all?
I think for a while, I thought we ultimately thought we should have identified it as a racial issue from the start.
And our hope was that rational thinking, white Memphis, which see this for what it was.
It was a labor dispute in the conditions, I mean, it could be reviewed by anybody.
What did happen, we found a way to take some well to do white women, to visit the homes of not so well to do African American women husbands of sanitation workers.
And they obviously couldn't believe what they were seeing.
And we had hoped that they would become a voice of both moderation and observation in this process.
And there was, there was enough pressure generated to get the mayor to participate in some forums, Q&A kind of stuff.
And when people heard the conditions on which the mayor worked, the other factors, you could see people's mind changes for a long part of the strike.
People just blindly committed to the positions that Mayor Henry Loeb III took without any discussion of whether or not they were accurate enough.
You mentioned just a few minutes ago that the strike had been resolved twice before. Can you talk about?
We are.
In the early days, one or two days after the strike started, several of the staff, people including myself, was in the mayor's office talking to the mayor trying to explain to him what was going on.
And it was a very simple process at that point. The men says they want to have the union speak for them.
And they want to talk about safety and health because you just had these men get killed in this.
And the mayor took the position that this is an illegal strike. And he would not talk to people who were breaking the law.
You know, which was about as backwards thinking as you could find. So we said, look, this is not complicated.
Let us sit down and talk about what we're trying to, trying to solve. And so he allowed one of his fellow fellow by the name of Janati, which was one of the city attorneys.
The Janati and a couple of us went into a side room and just started working on what do you think will take to get this resolved.
And so we came up with what we call a recognition clause, etc.
We agree with the committee agreed with it. And since Mr. Janati represented the mayor, we assume that he certainly wouldn't agree to anything, but the mayor didn't agree to it.
So we took it back to show him this one paragraph of paragraph and a half deal. And the mayor went bananas.
And so we kept saying, well, the hardest thing to do is to try and work with somebody who don't know what they're doing.
And so it was clear to us that they just had to hands full and have no background on what's taking place.
The second time, spring from a meeting that we had, which involves a mayor. And President Wurf was there.
We talked about the issues and each day the strike goes on, you get some new issues. Because the people are going through a little bit more pain.
So we finally found something that we thought everybody could agree on. It didn't involve money. None of that.
And the mayor said he thought he could live with that. Well, somebody from the mayor's side called the press, followed the meeting, and gave him a story.
And the next morning's headlines was Mayor Capitulates".
And you know, everything just unraveled. And he was taking polls in the white community. How many was for him? How many was against him?
And as long as he had his pro support out there in big numbers, he figured, why does he have to worry?
So he just walked backwards from the agreement we had reached. And ultimately, he never did come back into the discussions.
He put some city council people. Well, there was just one point to be make. There was a fellow there who, not necessarily pro-U. But he was pro-Fair.
And he, I worked with a number of the council members and had got enough. He was one vote short of getting the city council to get engaged and involved in a fine solution to this thing.
And his name was Lewis Donelson. I spoke to him years later and he said that he was just so dismayed. And it really took the burden himself with Dr. Martin Luther King Jr's assassination, because he just said he could never have, he did not find the one more vote that he thought he needed.
And that if he had been able to be more convincing, perhaps he would never would have happened. I'm not sure I agree with that, but that was his story.
In, after the assassination, we found ways and means of putting the language together to form an agreement. And the mayor stood back from it and allowed it to move forward through the city council. And by then it was about money.
And the mayor never put any money into the settlement. But one of the fairly wealthy industrialists there in Memphis fell about the name of Abe Plough, who owned Abe Plough, put up enough money to satisfy the demands that were on the table. And we then moved the contract towards ratification.
From what you were just saying and what I've read, it seems like Mayor (Henry) Loeb was a big stumbling block.
Well, he was it. I mean, there was no, I mean, the city council, the city council once recommended a resolution. And apparently they were jackhammered into back and away from that.
But Mayor (Henry) Loeb never engaged in it. He said, it was an illegal strike. And he wasn't going to break the law, which is a strange outlook for a major employer.
But in the end, the city council ratified the agreement. The workers ratified the agreement. And Loeb just went his merry way.
And the irony is that Loeb became a protester himself. I mean, he was a big agricultural issue in 69 or 70. I forget when the tractors all came to town.
He was watching the DC and circled the capital and did all this. Well, he was a leader in the tractor protest movement.
So do you take credit for teaching and protest? I kind of think that at some point in time he regretted having painted himself into a corner early in the strike.
He certainly did. And it became a question of face saving, even to do the right thing.
So Mr. Lucy, I know you said you had a meeting to go to and it's right about 12. Can I ask you just a couple of big questions about the rest of some of the other highlights.
I don't even know if that would be the right. And then you can pick and choose and answer what you.
So I know that you were instrumental or crucial in organizing the coalition of black trade unionists and also the free South Africa movement.
And of course, we're approaching the 50th anniversary of the March on Washington for jobs and freedom. And I know sometimes people miss that jobs part of the jobs and freedom and economic issues.
And sort of related to this to sort of the significance, I guess. Well, I'm thinking in terms of the coalition of black trade unionists sort of asked me, I understand, was a pretty white union when you joined it nationally. I don't know if that's right.
Actually, when we joined it, the percentage of people of color was higher, but the union was smaller.
Okay. Coalition of Black Trade Unionists came about really as a protest and reaction to the AFL CIOs.
Almost refusal to get engaged in the battle between George McGovern and Richard Nixon.
And I believe that I forget what year that election was, but 72.
72, I mean, you know, the endorsement process is critically important. And we had watched Richard Nixon for four years with his price controls and wage controls and his just over disdain for the African American and poor community.
So at the convention of the AFL-CIO prior to the Democratic National Convention, the AFL-CIO, we're taking a position of neutrality.
Which in our community suggests that one's no different than the other or one's no better than the other.
And we got Richard Nixon with a dreadful record with regards to working people, poor people, black people.
As opposed to McGovern, who had a progressive record, both in his participation in Congress and in the Senate, I should say.
Otherwise, so our view was clearly your decision to remain neutral does not take into consideration the impact that one candidate has had on our broad community.
And we believe that there was a real need for our voice to be in that process. And not that the AFL-CIO was wrong or bad, it just simply had not considered in the context of our interest what Nixon was and had done and would do.
And so some of us decided that we had to figure out how to make sure our voice was in the room.
So about four or five of the colleagues, Nelson Jack Edwards, Charles A. Hayes from what is now the United Food and Commercial Workers, which at that time was retail clerks, something like that.
Cleveland Robinson.
Well, that's one of William H. "Bill" Simons from the American Federation of Teachers.
We concluded that we already have a meeting just talk about what had just happened and to see how we can sort of influences process in years to come.
And we thought that rather than ourselves having all the wisdom, we all asked some other people.
So we set a meeting for Chicago and just sort of talked to people and said, here's what we're thinking about doing.
You want to be a part of this conversation, come to Chicago.
We didn't have a mailing list, a tweeter's a Twitter or email and that stuff, it's just word of mouth.
At this meeting, 1,300 trade union to show that.
And the surprise, we didn't even know there was that many out there.
But obviously it was an idea that lots of other people had thought about.
Some of them had actually done.
Mr. Randolph, a A. Philip Randolph, it had the Negro American Labor Council, I think it was legal.
And they had worked for a number of years.
Some of these same kinds of issues.
But there was never, it was not as serious then as it was in 1972.
So when we had the convention, we did not say we have formed Coalition of Black Trade Unionists.
And he said, we ought to take about a year and talk about this.
And we've got to be talked about in all parts of the country.
So lots of people were given assignments to go here, go there, meet with workers, meet with labor leadership, black leadership,
and raise the question, is this a time for such a zest?
And it was not set out to be a coalition of black trade unionists.
At the end of the day, we came back into a second convention.
And the answer in response to the question was yes.
We need an organization such as this to make sure our voices don't get lost.
And we intentionally called it Coalition of Black Trade Unionists.
I mean, with Malice of Fourth, I should say.
And the idea was to get people, I mean there's nothing wrong with diversity.
There's nothing wrong with people getting together to discuss mutual concerns.
But we said we've got to be very clear that issues we're going to deal with.
We're going to come back from a black perspective.
And everybody, I mean it's open to membership for everybody, but that's the focal point.
And the convention voted to name it that.
And we've grown to some 55 chapters now.
Some just dynamite coalitions of workers, some label only.
But it has brought to consciousness the focus that there are unique problems that women have in the workforce,
Hispanics have in the workforce, African-American.
And you can't sort of use a philosophy of 1948.
I mean, it's a little bit different now.
And do you think you've been able to have an impact through that on the sort of approach of the broader labor movement?
Well, I think so.
I mean, our initial argument was that we're not in the room with these decisions of the executive council
in those days were substantially smaller.
Now, I mean in 1955, we increased the council by 12 persons,
aside from those who may have gotten elected on their own.
But now it's a diverse policy-making body with women, with Hispanics, with Asians, with African-Americans.
So when you take on domestic economic policy, when you take on foreign policy,
I mean, you're speaking with the folks who are experiencing the impact of it on a daily basis.
With many whole high levels of leadership in their own individual organizations.
In those days, Mr. Randolph, I think, was probably the only African-American on the council,
perhaps C.L. Dellums and C.L. Dellums.
But the fact is that people have educated themselves as the role and value of trade unions.
And they are full participants, and we call ourselves full partners.
And we've lasted 43 years, a little bit longer than a lot of others.
But I think, you know, we're still going at it.
We're going to move Nelson Mandela.
Let me just spend a moment on that.
We have long since we've been coalition-black trade unions believe that apartheid was an abomination that should not exist.
And we have long held that there ought to be free and fair elections, not just in South Africa, but across the undeveloped world.
I mean, people ought to have an opportunity to participate in the decision that's who will lead them.
And apartheid was a special brand of evil that a lot of people made excuses for.
And it was go-alonged alone.
In 1984, I believe it was, we just started to look at this and how can a free labor movement really work side by side with something like apartheid.
Again, the American labor movement did not step up to the challenge in front of it.
So we took on the battle of sensitizing the country to the evils of apartheid, President Reagan, I believe, was an office at that time.
And we were set out with a specific goal to undo it, or disengage US policy from Africa in general, well, South Africa specifically.
Under the leadership of Randall Robinson, we have formed what is called TransAfrica.
And it was specifically a body to put black thought into foreign policy.
And in 1984, we took on the role of trying to form something that will spread this discussion in debate nationwide.
So we formed a free South Africa movement out of a number of other movements.
And it took a while, but we finally got there.
Nelson Mandela was ultimately released from prison, ultimately became president of South Africa.
And now is gravely ill.
But we have seen Africa in general and South Africa particularly move from colonial domination to independent democracies in many cases.
Why did you think it was important to bring Nelson Mandela here?
I think on his tour of 1990, and had two purposes, one to give him an opportunity to define and project what he sees for South Africa, what he saw for South Africa in terms of a non-racial society.
And second, let the country see someone who had spent 27 years in prison for expressing that thought in South Africa.
It was such an incredible impact on the country as a whole.
I think a lot of minds were changed. A lot of people were educated.
A lot of people became much more knowledgeable about the fact that there ought to be engagement in foreign policy.
We've been alive in South Africa since the apartheid inception and never complained about it once.
And whether it was regular, any others who proceeded, Republicans and Democrats alike.
And we found a rationale for continuing to relate to an evil system.
Could I ask a little bit about, do you think it's irrelevant? You don't have to answer.
After the apartheid was abolished in South Africa, there was a security of truth and reconciliation.
Do you think America needs such an acknowledgement of...
Well, I don't think there's any question that's a lot of issues that could be put before a truth commission to have folks either admit to that participation in it, argue for its larger existence.
I mean, if they can make that argument, I mean, you've got to have ongoing tragedies that grow out of our history and our systems across the South.
So we profess the need for democracy around the world, yet we sequirely buy while folks are denied the right to vote.
Or we rationalize the reason why they shouldn't vote.
As opposed to South Africa, who... or Brazil is mandatory that you vote.
I mean, I think if we want to really test our system, let's make voting mandatory.
And you would see the divisions that exist in the country with regards to who should participate in democracy.
And I think some of the past ills and racism that exists, not just in the South, but in the North as well, are let's say across the country.
I could really bear some airing out.
I think half people simply share their views. I mean, it really goes back to what he'd be the voice that the problem of our country is race.
I mean, we're debating now the comprehensive immigration reform.
I mean, who was here first? Everybody is immigrant of some type. And we're still debating those kinds of questions.
Mr. Lucia, I want to respect your time. So I know we all have many more questions, but thank you very much for being with us today. I appreciate it.
I really want to take a closer look.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.